Hillary Clinton bitter as
ever she refuses to give up
the spotlight and can't get over
her loss to Trump the failed
candidate is now being brutally
mocked for claiming 20 2020
Democrats also gathered a
Russian asset but of course
the New York Times is defending
her touting Clinton as quote
master troll welcome to Hillary
unplugged for most of her
public career Mrs. Clinton
has been constrained
by the expectations of her
position at first lady senator
or secretary of state now
after her stunning loss
in 2016 it seems
she finally feels
liberated to speak her mind,
Greg have you noticed a
liberated cricket Yes you know
I believe she is trolling
patrolling is now officially
an old person's word if the
New York Times is using it
it's like your granddad
putting on his baseball cap
on backwards on his way to a
black crows reunion you know
like it's like when you're
it's like when you're playing
Coldplay and your mom says,
well I like that song and you
just throw the album I got that
the Web word is dead now to me I
will never call anybody a troll
or talk about effective trolling
Thank you New York Times OK
what do you think about this
puff piece they seem to be
enamored with Hillary well that
actually Hillary Clinton thinks
the New York Times really did
her wrong in 2015 and 2016
remember, they're the ones
that broke the Clinton Global
Initiative story she thinks that
they gave the emails thing too
much attention et cetera
but you have to think
about all of us think, OK,
that's a I'll ask you this
week you had the last two
presidential runners up in
the news for the wrong reasons
so you even had Bernie
Sanders today saying, well,
I don't say that about Tulsi
Gabbard like we don't need
to have any of that
here Tulsi Gabbard
none gets all this
additional attention
and you have Mitt Romney.
So these two you mean what's
his name appear here that's from
two people who spent their
entire careers as viable
presidential candidates but they
were criticized because they
were too canned and too
scripted well now you're seeing
the other side of that do you
like this new Hillary one you
know she's tweeting she's saying
sassy things unplugged you know
to get back to Greg's analogy
right I mean this is her
she's you know I just to pick up
on what Dana was saying when I
look at people who lost
the presidential race
and so I'm looking at Mitt
Romney John McCain John
McCain was back in
the Senate going
after Barack Obama as I recall
mitt Romney's ran for senate and
won in Utah and now he's even
got something to say about Trump
right nobody sells these guys
to shut up so why would
you say oh Hillary the lady
should shut up I
don't think there
is I don't think that's fair.
And there's no way you know
Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi Gabbard is
not only you know in terms
of the possibility of Russia
wanting her and encouraging her
with all this stuff online she
said that no matter even if she
doesn't win the nomination she
plans to go to the convention
and create turmoil and I just
think what is are you rooting
against the Democrats even
as you run for the nominee kind
of like Ted Cruz cause turmoil
with Trump Oh Yeah you love
that oh what do you think
my favorite part of that New
York Times piece was for most
of her public
career Mrs. Clinton
has been constrained
by expectations
of her position and by
being first lady senator
secretary of State Hillary
Clinton has only been
constrained by trying to be
somebody she's not to be likable
to be understanding to be
empathetic rather
than just pathetic
her latest look is a has
been gasping for relevance.
This is the equivalent of a
72 year or almost 72-year-old
woman taking selfies and put
them on Instagram oh that's how
I don't know if anybody's ever
done that I don't know any
belfield I think those are Yes
it is interesting that this
piece runs now right that that
only now is Hillary Clinton
a master troll really Monica
Lewinsky oh wow what did you
want to bring up something and
also I was referencing emails
there was someone I think it was
on CNN Yes his name is Jeffrey
Jeffrey let's listen to Jeffrey
this is also a story about
the news media
about how much time
we spent on that and that's
something that I have
felt a great deal of
personal responsibility for.
I think I paid too
much attention to them.
And I regret that this story
turns out to be a big nothing
and we spent months
on it Hillary
Clinton very likely lost
the election because of it.
And I think I should have
been think talking about other
issues not about the emails
so let me get this straight
Jeffrey Toobin in his entire
life that's what he regrets
you'd think there'd
be other face no
that's and that's all
you were thinking about
covering Russia collusion.
Yeah Yeah Yeah having
that you know threats that
wasn't nothing nothing is right
but here's the fact the State
Department right this has been
investigated they said zero
and you guys Stole even
say you said 0 what
1 0 that he did nothing wrong.
There was no that here I
didn't do anything wrong Obama
didn't do anything wrong Hillary
did nothing wrong no one does
anything wrong wait a second
a minute ago you're saying OK
Trump is complaining because
oh this impeachment is terrible
it's not so the process when it
goes forward Hillary is found
to have no respect no nothing
is done wrong and you still
won't say call me let her
off the hook oh you know what
that's how the cookie crumbles.